[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh happy happy Tuesday everybody
yeah oh indeed somebody just got stabbed
it's New York City
's getting a lot of new faces you know
all those illegal aliens Joe Biden
invited into the country during his
presidential run they're here I haven't
seen this many single men since they dug
up cat's backyard
but mayor Adams he's not thrilled the
policies of a Democrat president are now
biting him in the ass like he's backed
into a hungry Brian stelter
so on Monday Adams announced that up to
50 churches or faith-based spaces for
fans of weird needless euphemisms we'll
soon shelter up to 19 single adult
illegal aliens each so that's 50 times
19. what's that amount to cats just
kidding you're a chick
oh I'm sorry
unnecessary really we'll have a meeting
after
so I think that's less than a thousand
but last week over twice that many
arrived in New York so any other bright
ideas Mr Mayor do you have a vision
it is my vision uh to take the next step
to this go to the faith base uh locales
and then move to uh private residence
they are residents who are suffering
right now because of economic challenges
they have spare rooms they have locales
and we can find a way to get over the
30-day Rule and other rules that
government has in in this place
so you got that move the migrants to
homes where current residents are
already suffering
well at least I hope it doesn't cost a
lot like 4.2 billion
we can take that 4.2 billion dollars 4.3
it may be now that we potentially have
to spend and we can put it back into
pockets of everyday New Yorkers everyday
houses of worship instead of putting in
the pockets of Corporations and some of
those corporations come from outside our
city
4.2 billion maybe 4.3 billion hey who's
counting well we are and that's a butt
load excuse my French but and we're
going to use it to pay people to let
dudes crash on your couch
have you seen some of the hotel
conditions where the migrants are
currently staying it's almost as
disgusting as my toilet after eating a
quart of rocky road
I'm lactose intolerant oh you think
that's funny
and besides couldn't you already rent
your rooms out and you could do a
background check on your tenants but
here how does that even work Adams
expects you to embrace the government
paying for a stranger to take your son's
top bunk bed it makes me yearn for the
good old days when we sent migrants
Upstate so they can cross into Canada
illegally but once they heard Nickelback
They begged to be shipped to Greenland
but the Democrats reality is always the
opposite of their earlier virtue signal
they like pretending they'll help but
they don't it's like when I pretend to
lift when I'm a pallbearer
but you should respect mayor Adams at
least for walking the walk so then how
about the mayor's house it has spare
rooms I'm sure
well
when asked about it he actually said
quote if it doesn't go against legal
protocols I don't have a problem if I
could put a migrant family in Gracie
Mansion wow
that's not bad they just have to dump a
bucket of water on the de Blasio so
they'll leave
but none of this makes any damn sense
like when do we stop paying how many
people do we take in will they get to
stay longer or forever and you can't
come out if they keep eating your
Funyuns
and also have we lost our damn Minds I
mean if there was just some process that
could deal with illegal immigration I
don't know something like a wall or
maybe just follow the damn laws
meanwhile on the other coast controlled
by democrats Sacramento is freaking out
over 16 illegals 16 flown in on a
private jet first of all a private jet
hell I've seen 16 in a flatbed truck
but now the dem's hair is on fire
especially this guys
which makes sense maybe stop putting
axle grease in your hair
and guess who he's blaming quote Ron
DeSantis you small pathetic man this
isn't Martha's Vineyard kidnapping
charges
so can you imagine the governor of the
most screwed up state in the Union
calling the governor of the most
successful State pathetic that's like a
last place team during the league Champs
I would be more specific but I know
nothing about sports
and he's calling private jets that
people willingly get on as kidnapping so
I guess that makes our entire airline
industry a human trafficking cartel
I suppose stems only support flying
illegals when it's done secretly in the
dead of night the problem of Gavin his
residents are flying too straight out of
California the homeless problem is so
bad in Cali they're going to change its
motto from the Golden State to the
golden shower state
so no worry Gavin as soon as these 16
illegals get there and see the squalor
they'll head to Florida too
so in some when Dems ship illegal
somewhere else it's good with DeSantis
does it it's a hate crime and the White
House is happy to Echo that notion
I've said it many times from here
repeatedly uh from from this Podium that
bussing or flying migrants around the
country without any coordination with
the federal government we've talked
about this uh state or local officials
as well is dangerous and unacceptable
because you're putting people's lives at
risk and it's dangerous and it's
unacceptable because you're actually
putting a lot of pressure on these
states and local uh and local local
areas
she's stupid
unintentionally honest though the
message is clear if you live in a border
state with millions of people pouring in
good luck to you but don't you dare drop
them off in blue cities because that's
dangerous
and funny how honest that really is
a desk Michigan still remembers her as
The One That Got Away former Michigan
GOP candidate for governor tutor Dixon
and just don't ask him where that finger
has been
oh now you know put up your finger oh
it's there it's coming
host of Across America Jimmy Bayla
his act comes with a warning may cause
drowsiness comedian Joe Mackey
and like a warm summer evening she
attracts bugs
Buffs just contributor captive
how you doing Joe not too shabby Greg
how about yourself how about you how are
you doing I'm doing great man you
buzzfeeding you got your collar popped I
got my colourpopped it's like Elvis's 68
Comeback Special tonight yes
you look like you're starring in a show
about a tame biker gang like mild Hogs
yeah
says Liberace gay or brother
I I do I look like a children's magician
who doesn't belong around children yeah
I agree the minute I put it on yeah okay
so Joe you actually live in a showroom
at Raymond and Flanagan right
would you be comfortable housing
numerous illegal migrants in your home
Greg it would be a it could be a bad
situation for everybody yeah going
forward because like what if I've got a
lady over and things are getting Amorous
you know I can't have my style cramped
plus like you know what if I like to
walk around naked and enjoy country
music they're not going to enjoy that no
they won't
it's just a fascinating situation where
where the left is surprised that
anything has consequences you know like
uh open borders oh people might cross
them yeah
and if you give people free crack pipes
I might enjoy delicious crack yes
I don't think I have enjoyed anything
more than Tudor dicks or Mac Dixon
imagining something that you said
right
I saw your face the country music line
made you nauseous no I yes because I
thought when we when I was looking at
this I thought this could be so
dangerous for the New Yorkers but then I
realized that it could actually be
dangerous for the migrants yes they
could end up with this I mean how bad
would that be yes you end up in some but
really it is dangerous either way I mean
if we are being honest about this and we
think about this truly you are talking
about putting people into someone's home
who we he admitted these people are
vulnerable they they're vulnerable
people it's they have why I don't know
how they have an extra room so where are
they putting them I mean we are it's
foster care for undocumented citizens
illegal aliens whatever you want to call
it but it's incredibly dangerous and
they're like we'll just own a room in
your home I've got look I've got all
this money yeah I got all this money
just take it by the way the money then
becomes
incentive it's an incentive yes so if
you do 125 a day it comes with 3 500 a
month per person so think about that
thirty five hundred dollars a month I
mean that's almost as much as I make in
a day it's very
it's very reminiscent of paying nursing
homes to take patients and to look how
that turned out exactly that's a great
Point boom speaking of the opposite
Jimmy oh
um should we give uh mayor Adams a
little bit of credit unlike Gavin Newsom
he's actually saying okay we're
sanctions I'm not crazy about being a
sanctuary City but we're Sanctuary
cities so I'm going to do my best I mean
yeah that was the gig and you got to
look at the positives like we're working
on a great friend spin-off if all the
migrants fill in you have a department
called Amigos like that would be pretty
funny
and as a parent you think of like the
Border themed kids games you could play
like pin the tail on the drug mule
that's going to be hot uh you can't play
Red Rover because they've already sent
everyone over that's the only problem
but the whole thing is so stupid because
this is all a consequence of their
actions and now obviously they're trying
to abandon it but think about this at
the southern border we've had 200 people
that we know of on the terror watch list
okay that we know of okay so it means
there's not all good people coming over
how does that conversation go with your
kids you're like you know you guys
always wanted a big brother well you're
getting one but he doesn't speak English
you know what I mean and uh he likes to
fly do you guys like to fly I mean it's
bad that was a little dark okay it's
okay no uh um cat uh
this kidnapping line can we talk about
is is Gavin Newsom really stupid to like
to actually say was he like does he
actually believe that this is kidnapping
well I don't think he came up with it
someone else was like call it kidnapping
that makes you sound passionate yeah and
so he said you're right I'll go with
that uh no I I I yeah I don't think he
really does but well I don't how much of
the things that they say do politicians
overall generally believe I think they
probably just want the fiery hot takes
um I don't know I think obviously a lot
of these issues do come with the fact
that there are incentives and it's not
migrants themselves so what we're
talking about a lot of these cases is
economic issues the idea of housing
um I always knew Eric Adams was out of
touch a little bit but the idea of
housing a migrant in your house who in
Manhattan has a house yeah that's that's
true yeah no one has a where yeah
like I can't even do like a YouTube
aerobics video in my apartment without
bruising myself all over because I'm
kicking it all the time
I tried yeah that's true I if it so if
it's 35 you get 3 500 a month and you
take you could just take in five people
that's like eighteen thousand dollars
eighteen thousand dollars a month I mean
you're almost rich in theory the money
makes sense but who's paying for their
groceries yeah like the government's
giving you money to cover their rent but
now they're just in your house yeah so
how does that work if they're like
eating the food or wearing your clothes
or think about all the spin-off porn
like Debbie does Dominican Republic like
it's gonna be dead no is anything to
work in his place I mean you think of
where this is going you know what it is
what you're talking about though is is
like squatters yeah if you can't get rid
of people that actually rent what
happens here that's what I'm saying
you'll never get them out yeah exactly
that's so stupid all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else